Florida Republican Governor Ron DeSantis
is now trying to cut LGBT subject matter
from an advanced placement psychology
class that is taught in Florida as an
optional class and the College Board
good for them is saying no the bigger
story here well there's really two
stories here there's three stories
there's 12 no there's three as far as I
can tell one is the subject matter and
the curriculum of this advanced
placement psychology class which we'll
talk about in a moment the second part
of it is the continued quote anti-woke
war that Ron DeSantis is fighting in the
State of Florida and thirdly is that
this is yet another example of how
right-wingers claim to have a particular
value but then as soon as that value is
inconvenient they abandon it and I will
tell you about that in a moment and it
has everything to do with this subject
matter being in a psychology class which
based on their previous statements is
something you would think think they
would be okay with so let's go to the
beginning what is going on USA Today
reports Ron DeSantis wants to scrub AP
classes of lgbtq subjects the College
Board isn't having it and uh it says
another Showdown over advanced placement
courses could be brewing in Florida this
time over AP psychology as the
non-profit that runs the program the
College Board
faces pressure from State officials to
remove or revise lessons on sexual
orientation and gender identity the
conflict is another example of how
DeSantis is pushed to restrict how race
and lgbtq issues are taught is impacting
Florida schools Florida's Department of
Education sent a letter to the College
Board asking them to review all AP
courses to see if they need modification
to ensure compliance with a Florida law
that targets instruction on sexual
orientation and gender identity the
message is clear
remove that stuff the College Board
responded with a defiant letter late
last week saying we will not modify our
courses to accommodate restrictions
teaching essential college-level topics
this could be a showdown and this class
could become a source of conflict uh the
hill also reporting college board says
it won't alter AP courses to comply with
Florida laws they put out a letter
saying that this is not something that
they are going to do adding doing so
would break the fundamental promise of
advanced placement colleges wouldn't
broadly accept the course for credit and
that course wouldn't prepare students
for careers in the discipline so let's
talk about what it is that is going on
here first of all this is you know as
usual the way that the anti-woke Florida
people want to frame these stories are
this is extremely inappropriate stuff
being taught to kids the reality of
course is that this is and advanced
placement class it's overwhelmingly High
School seniors
and some high school juniors
occasionally a sophomore if they're a
real go-getter you know what I mean but
it's overwhelmingly seniors and juniors
who are either this year or next year
going to be adults it is an optional
class relatively few people take
advanced placement classes I'm not
saying over the raw number is low but
relatively few people take these classes
when I took AP economics in high school
that was the one AP class I took it
represents it was 12 students out of 900
or something like that uh and that was
it so nothing is being pushed on anybody
these are almost legal adults and most
importantly and this is the point the
College Board is making AP level classes
are
equivalent to college classes you
sometimes get credit I was able to skip
right to uh intro to macroeconomics with
Richard Wolff by the way at the
University of Massachusetts my first
semester because I got credit for AP
micro from high school so if you
arbitrarily say we're going to change
around what's in this class the class is
designed to be a college equivalency
class in college in Psychology class
lgbtq issues are part of the subject
matter if you arbitrarily remove that
from the AP High School class you
endanger that class actually being a
college equivalency class so it is
undeniably now let me get now to this
next issue so first and foremost doesn't
make any sense to remove it makes
perfect sense to have this content there
uh if you are a right winger now I I
what this is an if okay we're doing
abstract thinking if you are one of the
right Wingers who writes to me and says
David whether it's trans even if it's
gay all of this stuff is merely mental
illness there's no biological basis for
lgbtq it's just mental illness by that
standard a psychology class is the
correct place for this subject matter
this is a college equivalent psychology
class I'm not supporting this view but
what I'm saying is if you have the view
that lgbtq issues are merely issues of
mental health that should not be taught
to quote kids
then what better place for them than in
a college equivalent psychology class
another reminder that they don't
actually mean the things they say they
love saying these subjects shouldn't be
in science class they shouldn't be in
Biology class well maybe they should or
maybe they shouldn't it's quite a large
amount of scholarship on that but if
they shouldn't and you believe these are
simply mental illnesses then if not in a
college equivalent psychology course
where the hell do you put this subject
matter so there's two different views on
what DeSantis is doing here it's mere
pandering to continue this veneer of an
anti-woke warrior in Florida who will
bring that anti-woke perspective to the
Oval Office if he is elected
I don't know that it's just pandering
because this is actual uh legislative
this there is plenty of legislation that
DeSantis has actually signed into law
these haven't just been PR battles that
go along these lines they hate
legislation in Florida under DeSantis
has been going on for a period of time
now that there may be a pandering
element to it but it is much more than
mere pandering that we can write off so
that's the latest battle by the way I
will restate this doesn't overall I mean
listen Maybe you get away with this a
lot of people won't even hear about this
a lot of these things the hardcore
anti-woke trans stuff the abortion
restrictions fighting Disney there
actually doesn't seem to be that much of
an appetite for this nationally and it
may end up hurting DeSantis or at least
not helping him catch up to Donald Trump
which is at the end of the day what he
needs to do right now in the Republican
primary
one of our sponsors today is replace
your mortgage mortgages are a really
interesting thing in the United States
the poor often can't afford them and the
rich often don't use them instead the
wealthy use special Financial tools to
pay off their debts often in a fraction
of the time that it takes for a
middle-class American to realize that
same payoff replace your mortgage
teaches you how you can pay off your
home in five to seven years without
needing to make more money than you're
currently making right now and in
addition they can teach you how to
better utilize your existing assets and
Equity to beginner continue growing
wealth and passive income through
additional strategies and they actually
have an upcoming Workshop that will show
you how you can take advantage of these
strategies how it all works create your
own economy in a sense you can go to
replace your universe city.com slash
Pacman to watch the interview I did with
their founder Michael Lush to learn how
you can get exclusive access to what can
be a life-changing virtual event the
link is in the description